you should have seen us trying all the
different lip brushes we were all like
ripping it on a lip sight she's not soft
enough yeah
how did the idea for the brand because
next rung come about is it something
you've always wanted to do
yeah literally always something to do
what one sort of makeup range and I
think we just had to wait for the rate
like time yeah we really wanted to make
sure after we did it we were gonna do it
properly and do it well I think we're
all very much like comfortable on the
skin and you know exactly what we like
to wear makeup wise what we wanted to
create so yeah it's definitely the
perfect timing to do it now which
product took the longest to perfect one
of the hardest to get right was probably
the show out palette you know the lip
palette oh yeah that was hard because
the slightest little torn difference
changes the lip completely do you not I
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah how it feels on
your lips as well and I got one mine was
too sticky and I thought oh no can't be
doing that like so it's so much you
actually have to delve into like there's
so many different things that come with
it yeah but we've had so much fun doing
it though like can't believe like this
is our brand I know
and what's something that people were
surprised to know that you're involved
with doing when it comes to the products
well we came up for the names for all
the shades and so all of the like with
the eyeshadow palette every single shade
it's like references like one of our
songs or luring yeah and from the get-go
we've been involved in the whole process
yeah what she is they are the texture
looks feel yeah everything the packaging
design we've been involved with every
year and that was really important for
us as well to like if it's our name to
this brand like it has to be done well
and properly so yeah if you could pick
one product from the range to help the
rest of your life this bad boy I've got
this on today where it's a long
religiously yeah one kiss Alexa's time I
like it and then matte lip right it's
really hard sites whimsical so yeah
sticky like it's there's a lot of thick
texture
yeah yeah yes if you could only use
three makeup products of the rest of
your life what would they be and why
oh dami lip because I can't live if I
think your lip and we always say not
when you're feeling rough just put
sunglasses on and a lane and no one
would ever know for me and I think you
say it well I need a brow gel like I
have to comb them out so they're in
position in position yeah and the
highlighter I think no matter how rough
you feel and how well have you put a bit
of highlighter over you know the
cheekbones bit on your eyebrow bone you
just feel like a different person yeah
could you describe your signature makeup
look in three words oh I like a glowy
PGI
and I just love a good lip they're
really quite natural and not a lot or
it's like full shebang gems yeah yeah I
all out so would say all or nothing for
me a little bit of shimmer Eagles and
stuff I'm definitely feeling yeah than
natural look I feel like it suits me the
most because my eyes are quite like yeah
so I think we've just sort of like
individual lashes or lash I just think
that's yeah suits me and then maybe just
my frown lip which I love dear lover in
the elements collection deal there yeah
best beauty tip you ever learned from
makeup artist tips a good one Brandon
but when I sit into my own makeup it
takes me forever and I can't get that
kind of winged I shall do we look so I
put tape on my I blend and then when you
peel the tape off you've got like hmm
have you ever overcome a body or beauty
hang-up something that really bothered
you and now you like the vibe
yeah all of us which we have owes to
hate that always curvy and now a lot got
genuinely want quite sexy that I'm good
yeah good what advice would you give to
young women who are feeling the pressure
of social media and like living their
best life on Instagram you need to know
that the percentage that you see on
Instagram is the percentage these people
want you to see of their perfect life
yeah they don't wake up looking that
fantastic and they don't go about their
day looking that fantastic 24/7 it's
what they want you to think it isn't
real this apps there's filters there's
everything I think everyone's been kind
of victim to it where you feel that you
have to look perfect to get likes or
things like that but I think like you
said there's a completely different
movement now and I think now is the time
more than ever that we need to start
showing people that that's a load of
bull it's not real yeah and everyone's
different and that's why you should
embrace it what is your best advice for
kind of women supporting other women
instead of trying to tear each other
down I think we well we hope to be an
example of that like we are so
supporting each other we really do need
to just stick together yeah don't we and
I think it's so good now like seeing all
the movements that are happening and
women really are making a stand and
speaking up and I think that's what
we're trying to do as well I think we
have to spread the most positive message
we possibly can and yeah we're sticking
together so so so cute
you
[Music]